we're going to do is robbing to get an
audience participation where each person
on the panel is going to just say a few
comments of general comments either
we're at their seat or at the podium
whichever they're more comfortable with
it's a little crowded there we want to
try to bring the audience into a
discussion of Vietnam and the 72
campaign
they're both interchangeable in many
ways so instead of doing large warm-ups
or introductions here I'll make them
very brief and I think well it might be
the best Steve do you want to come ups
this is your talk there yeah what he's
just going to make a few comments on his
paper and then we'll just very briefly
then we'll start going through each
panelist to make a couple remarks
thanks a lot Doug and it's certainly an
honor for me to be associated with this
symposium and in particular this
distinguished panel certainly I've
considered staying up here all day just
to receive the globe from them but I I
promise you I will be very brief amid
the aftermath of the 1968 election
George McGovern chaired the Commission
on party structure and delegate
selection a name the press simplified to
the McGovern Commission ultimately its
members developed a series of guidelines
designed to increase the number of
presidential primaries and to make
delegates to future conventions more
responsive than in the past to
rank-and-file democrats the commission
also served as a catalyst for the birth
of a new brand politics within the party
the relatively successful efforts to
reform the party not only vaulted the
Commission recommendations into party
law but also diluted the traditional
influence of labor and local party
bosses in favor of more progressive
activists Democrats you all know the the
story of the 72 campaign so I won't go
over that but suffice it to say that the
in general the regard for the campaign
has remained unchanged since 1972 as New
York Times put it McGovern ran a gallant
campaign and showed his confidence in
the rightness of his
vision of America but the editorial
acknowledged that because of his
political political base being too
narrow the social outlook allegedly too
radical McGovern lost since then
neoconservative analysts have come into
the fray as well and as subsequent
presidential elections have seen the
demise of a Democratic Party
Ronald radish offered the newest of
these of this interpretation and his
title is in fact the book of his is
called divided they felt that the demise
of the Democratic Party it focuses on
the political effects of the reform
movement and he places the demise of the
Democrats squarely on the shoulders of
George McGovern and the reform
commission he chaired I quote from him
during the party to liberal constituency
groups and activists rather than to
traditional traditional Democratic
electorate McGovern opened up the party
to a course that would over the decades
result in a steady loss of electoral
support as you'll be all glad to know my
paper is a rejection of this
interpretation I was expecting applause
very good erroneously critics of the
McGovern Commission depend upon the
clarity of hindsight to distort the
party's reaction to the events of 1968
by focusing on the Republican victories
in the presidential elections of the
1970s and 80s and moving backward radish
and other neoconservatives
have neglected the context in which the
Democrats formed their political
strategies in the late 1960s and early
70s instead of viewing the McGovern
permission as a reasonable response to
Nixon's victory in 68 critics dismiss it
as ideological folly they inferred that
had the Democrats not reformed
themselves the party would have chosen a
stronger candidate in 1972 and perhaps
defeated Nixon in turn they conclude
that the party would have stemmed the
tide and conservatism that's that
surfaced in the 1980s radishes work
suffers in
from his attempt to defend this negative
supposition in his book he not only
ignored the strategy that the Democratic
Party developed in the aftermath of the
68 election but he also overlooked
evidence suggesting that the reform
effort had rejuvenated the party by 1970
my paper examines the first two years of
the McGovern Commission 1969 and 1970
during this period McGovern and other
party leaders focused almost exclusively
upon the results of the election in 1968
and followed a path that they believed
would revitalize the Democratic Party
those who served on the McGovern
Commission and supported its work did so
as a rationale and well at
well-intentioned response to the
election results indeed the McGovern
Commission soon became the most dynamic
entity within the party eventually the
fervor of reform oriented groups the
vast voting potential of a new
generation of young voters and the
results of the midterm elections of 1970
convinced party leaders including George
McGovern other reform paths promised in
some McGovern and the Democrats chose to
reform the party for the most compelling
reason a reformed party structure
appeared to offer the best chance for
future electoral success thank you very
much
should have mentioned Steve Ward's at
American University and he's working on
up his a project on this so he I'm sorry
you had to give them a truncated version
of that but it'll be one of the papers
in the book we have so many people here
from 72 campaign and we'll just start
with Bob Shrum on that end and then
we'll go to 200 Thompson but let's begin
with Bob strum I think we all know cover
the campaign and is a leading journalist
in America nope that's Hunter hunter
covered some version of the campaign uh
I don't appoint uh I was lucky enough
and fortunate enough to to have senator
McGovern and John holem and Frank
mankiewicz let me join the campaign as a
speechwriter it was one of the best
experiences of my entire life
I believe the campaign made three
singular contributions first senator
McGovern told the truth about two great
issues Vietnam and Watergate I remember
at one point in the fall we got some
polling advice saying people weren't
really buying this and we should talk
maybe about some other things and I
remember his reaction is then what am i
running for it was a rare example I
think of what one ought to do in
politics which is actually stand for
something one believes secondly he
became and I think this is often
forgotten a Tribune of issues that we're
going to move to the center of future
debate and change in America I think
first of tax reform and simplification
which Time magazine at the time in the
middle of the campaign wrote a piece
saying this will be an issue for the
next generation secondly of campaign
reform and Public Integrity when he said
this is the most corrupt administration
in American history he got a lot of
criticism it was true and he really
advanced I think the whole cause of
running different kinds of campaigns and
thirdly at least for a lot of us in a
time of disillusion and cynicism
he gave an example of integrity and
grace he wasn't desperate he didn't run
around looking for something he could
say that would please people at the
moment and ultimately he was driven by
principle and not polls and gimmicks I
think there were three tragedies in the
campaign first the nation never really
saw senator McGovern for the principled
and sensible person he was that was
partly our fault
the acceptance speech was given at 3:00
a.m. in the morning wasn't his fault he
couldn't do anything about it at that
point I mean we were trapped in a
process that was very protracted
secondly I think 72 with the exception
of Hunter and bill greider and a few
other people saw the rise of horse race
reporting in the decline of substance
coverage I remember at one point the
senator gave a very serious and proposal
on the environment big speech the only
place that was covered was in the New
York Times and I asked several reporters
what happened and they said people don't
want to hear about that thirdly the
Eagleton affair
I think damaged us very greatly I do not
myself think that we would have won
without it but I think we would have won
ten states or so and then I think George
McGovern would have been viable far into
the future as a presidential candidate I
have two vivid memories of election
night the first is personal it's John
holem and sandy Berger and I sitting on
the floor in the room with Senator
McGovern and he looked down and smiled
at us and said there they are the men
who wrote the words that move the nation
if in his in his concession speech he
quoted at least Stevenson quoting
Lincoln and looking back over 25 years
and I find it hard to believe it's 25
years I'd paraphrase that quote if you
look back at that campaign 25 years
later it still hurts too much to laugh
but it was way too glorious and too
authentic to ever cry
we wanted to have Bob go first because
he may be having to take off in a few
minutes that's why we're trying to get
him to the beginning of it uh where does
begin Hubert Humphrey railing summer
well well let the our next speakers dr.
hunter is Thompson who I think you all
are familiar with a political journalist
fiction writer and also wrote of course
the campaign trail 1972 is a new book
coming out now called the proud highway
which is a collection of his letters
which will be out in June and I think
Jenna turma governs called the book
campaign trail 72 fear and loathing on
the campaign trail the best book that
emerged out of that out of that campaign
so hunter oh well let's say thank you
George for that [ __ ] thing coming
toward is alright
we only alright
hi I'm not sure what to say but you're
talking about Sioux Falls South Dakota
they're right that like flexion like yes
that remains one of the truly heinous
nights of my life
and in memory it's like a deep you're
those cars at heels but has nerve
endings loosen it and you know it is all
time or we could hang it on something or
when it rains yeah I was a nasty night
but the I might have speaker I'm just
going to say hello we can talk to people
I was not prepared for a speech like
Bob's as well here mankiewicz try to
explain why this happened and why that
everything has been criticized in the
moments of other people speaking what
all traces back Frank to you light my
light so hell I don't blame George he's
a decent man but ye gods and we have to
look at the root of maybe perhaps
whether the most decent delegate may be
foolish campaigns ever and David take it
over by a dark up like
franker that was another one of my major
experiences that camping just dealing
with mega woods I didn't know he had
water well but I just stood but the
principles have made him move and let me
tell you that frankerz frankerz darker
than almost anybody ever seen he no I
don't come back I'll give you my moments
here for a second so you can indecency
this it's my good friend Frank
mankiewicz Frank do you want to jump in
on this come on in right just there
every once in a while
Connor come hunter I guess he hasn't for
a while but he used to come to
Washington fairly regularly and stay
with us I think I used to know when
Hunter was due to come to Washington
because I would start to get his mail he
would have it forwarded which was a sure
sign that soon he would be on our
doorstep but he hasn't done it lately
I'm not sure why I I don't know what the
senator McGovern said about honor his
book fear and loathing on the campaign
trail but I haven't quoted many times
and I'll say it again it was the most
accurate and least factual account of
that camp
there's a lot yeah you want to think
about that just a few brief comments
here I think there's a lot I'm sorry to
maybe think less of the rules the new
rules and the government Commission and
the all the rest that I don't think it
had that much of an impact I think
George McGovern would have won the
nomination under any set of rules
because he had the issue no question
that overwhelming majority of voters in
what was at 21 Democratic primaries felt
strongly about Vietnam war as he did and
I believe we the one as it was he won 11
primaries I think he probably would have
won that many maybe a few more so I just
I don't think the rules changes had that
much impact and I don't think it's
rather widely known the George McGovern
didn't even favor all the rules changes
I think if you go back and look and
listen to some of the things he was
saying he probably thought the
Commission maybe went a little too far
in some areas I think George would have
liked to protect winner-take-all at
least in California at least in 1972 and
maybe a few other less drastic changes
but as I say I don't think it mattered
I've read something of what mr. is it
ravish had to say I don't understand why
anybody spends any time on him at all
here's a guy along with others along
with others in in the in the mid 90s
early nineties who decided the
Democratic Party was finished and wrote
a book about it only to discover that
we've now won two presidential elections
in a row and probably are set to win the
third and maybe take back to Congress
again or certainly it's far from a party
that is what's the word that has had its
demise people are expecting or be they
read the New York Times enough and they
read about all the angry white
males in the side of the Democratic
Party was indeed finished and then found
out they were wrong so I think we can we
can do without any further serious
consideration of those guys and writers
of course only exemplifies a large
number I want to talk about one thing in
the campaign that Bob's from talked
about which was the the emergence of I
think an entirely different view of
campaigning and politics in the American
media it was as it turns out the hinge
between print coverage and television
coverage by 1976 you had a purely
television campaign 1968 I think it had
been largely print 1972 you also found
however an extraordinary overtaking of
campaign coverage by what has been
called I think accurately the the Teddy
white syndrome Teddy was a marvelous
political reporter who wrote a book in
1960 all the making of the president
1960 and then wrote one each four years
after that and he really did
revolutionize political coverage because
he stayed with the campaign's and he
wrote about things that nobody had
written about before yeah money how
campaign contributions were developed
endorsements how you got sheriffs to
support the campaign what it meant in
West Virginia to have certain people for
you and against you how campaigns were
conducted polling fundraising all the
rest of the speech writing all the the
techniques of campaigning and very
little on the substance which he wasn't
trying to get at but he was talking
about how campaigns were conducted and
how eventually they were won and lost
and that book had a profound influence
on everybody I think almost everyone who
wrote about politics for a living and I
think the American press the political
press ever since have tried very hard
without thinking about it to write that
book every day
and those are the issues that you hear
about those are the issues that are
endlessly chewed over
I remember one memorable day and in
Illinois senator McGovern I think I
think it was sandy burger maybe was Bob
Shrum but in any event they had
uncovered another terrible scandal in
the Nixon administration which was that
to put it fairly bluntly the
administration sold out the wheat
farmers in order to get the Soviet Union
to shut up when we bombed the harbor and
Haiphong that's about what it came down
to and the result was that there was
this terrible green scandal the
administration had downplayed the amount
of grain that the Soviet Union was going
to want and finally when they wanted a
great deal price was low they made a
disadvantageous deal for the wheat
farmers the Assistant Secretary of
Agriculture wound up with a new
apartment in New York and a job with one
of the big grain companies it was a hell
of a speech and he gave the speech in
his first stop in downstate Illinois in
wheat country and I remember going over
with the reporters the key phrases in
the speech to be sure they caught it all
and got all the basic charges and when
the speech was over senator McGovern
entertained the press that was traveling
with us and some of the ones who had
come over for the speech and the first
question and the second question and the
third question and the fourth question
all concerned this key Teddy white issue
here you are in Illinois for your first
visit in the campaign how come
mayor Daly wasn't here to greet you
legitimate question to be sure but
hardly the most important one that day
at that time for that speech and I think
that's that became fairly typical of the
coverage in 1972 and it has been fairly
typical of the coverage ever since are
you good at something meeting for only
indirectly we'd like to get Morris Dees
in on this
Morris is one of the sponsors at
Southern Poverty Law of the symposium
which were grateful for and Morris was
involved with fundraising the 72
campaign I thought he might want to say
words about that thank you Doug allows I
was rather glad to get the call in 1971
from sent McGovern to come to Washington
to help him get a letter out announcing
his campaign I was glad because having
sued George Wallace to integrate the
all-white state troopers in 1970 I'd
rather limited my political career in my
home state but when I was I was driving
to the airport to take the flight to
Washington I was listening we have other
conservative state in Central Grove and
parently one hill and two-hybrid God
considered unpatriotic and I was
listening to Merle Haggard song okie
from Muskogee and I never will forget
the line when you putting down my car my
country halls she walking on the fight
inside of me so I arrived in Washington
with some trepidation but I was met by
Henry Kimmelman who I wish was here
today in miles Rubin and Stan Kaplan and
others who helped me work on the
fundraising that made this campaign
possible turned to a government
certainly was supported by millions of
individuals in this country and in
direct mail it only took getting the
letters to the right people with the
help of Tom Collins who's a brilliant
copywriter we wrote a letter announcing
his campaign in 1970 to central
government I think through some of his
aides had written a little one-page
letter and I said senator you know we've
got to tell the whole story and he
allowed me to read all of his speeches
and we wrote a seven-page letter to mail
out he didn't like the seven-page letter
because some of his educated friends
Harvard said it wasn't going to work
he'd be the laughingstock so we mailed
the seven-page letter anyway without him
knowing it and I never really forget of
touching instant in that campaign
because I've been in the direct mail
business all my life and I knew that
long letters out pull little short
letters so Pat Donovan who's sitting
here today called me up come back to the
Senate office we used the Senate
letterhead and today you can't do that
but we did then and those letters had
come back the returned bad addresses and
central government parentage seen one of
them and so he I said well I can't come
I'm trying a case back home I'll come
soon I wanted some results to hopefully
come in
well central government call
mean he may not remember this but I
remember well he called me and not said
Morris he said and he began to read a
letter he had gotten from a woman who
had received and sent to him a ten
thousand dollar check and that's what
the federal government paid somebody who
lost their son in Vietnam and she had
sent that cheque in an envelope to send
to McGovern and said that that he she
wanted him to have that cheque instead
of her she didn't want that blood money
and from then it's always history since
we collected twenty four million dollars
from some 600,000 people and I think
that was just a token though that was a
token of the grassroots support and it
wasn't just some young people we got
letters from people sending their Social
Security check saying that they had been
around long enough to know that
President Nixon and others was wrong and
Senator McGovern was right I want to
thank sentient government here today
also when that campaign was over for
letting the Southern Poverty Law Center
have full access to those six hundred
thousand people and he wrote the first
letter out say asking them to support
our organization and today we have three
hundred fifty thousand supporters
Senator McGovern is one of our biggest
ones thank you
you know it was out it was very
interesting this morning when that one
of the speakers pulled out a check but
she had sent to Senator McGovern for
$5.00 because most of those checks that
Morris is talking about were in very
small denominations $10 $20 $30 dear
senator McGovern I don't have much money
but I want to stop the war the little
bank that we did business with across
the street from the K Street
headquarters which in itself was an
adventure was getting around 5,000
10,000 checks a day and the the manager
of the bank came across Street see Gerry
hearten and me and said these are
essentially uncollected funds somebody
is going to have to sign for these
uncollected funds who can stand good for
them because we don't know whether
they're good or not and you keep asking
me for the money because you want to buy
television time that day or radio time
long story short I signed for them and
out of 24 million dollars and out of
tens of thousands of cheques there were
seven thousand dollars were the bad
cheques there that which is the smallest
percentage anybody ever heard of
anywhere and there was a kind of
innocence with that political
contributions to the McGovern campaign
and what George McGovern deserves great
credit for since he is the last
presidential candidate to do this was to
spawn a group of people who refused to
be cynics some of them are old like me
and some of them are younger and a lot
of them are in the Clinton
administration the Bob is that smart
enough pardon that's morals unions in
that we learned something from well I
think I think it's important to believe
in what you're for and I detest the fact
that there are so many young people
today who are constantly telling me in
Charlotte North Carolina that politics
doesn't matter when in fact it matters
to everybody and it's because the nature
of the candidates and the compromise
with television and the compromise with
principle because otherwise you can't
get to
400,000 dollar contribution from the
liggett Meyers tobacco company and that
bothers the hell out of me because all I
give a damn about are my three
grandchildren and I want them to have
the better world that I thought we were
working for that I worked for in many
campaigns with Frank in Kennedy
campaigns and in the McGovern campaign
and I regret none of it I am grateful
for all of it
the hell with the Nixons of the world
for now and forever in or out of the
grave and I'm not sure he won't come
back I think why don't we open it up to
the audience a little bit and you could
direct your questions to the group or an
individual anybody want to start off
come on pick up somebody up there yes
sir it has to be some Nazi yes I'd like
to address this to mr. mankiewicz uh we
heard what my Franco said when he called
you he quoted you as as saying that you
would not have that the the candidate
Senator McGovern would never have said
to the lady on the Ozark Airlines plane
of what he said I'm wondering if you
might comment on the Ann Arbor Michigan
incident and harbor huh oh all right
well I'm dumps very simple matter
senator we're going to get a lot of heat
those days I think it was in it was the
sight of the Jackson State Prison in in
Michigan and he was working the fence
and when he finished some reporter who'd
been following him for the pool I guess
came to me and said well you know some
kid was giving senator McGovern a hard
time and the senator said to him listen
buddy you can kiss my ass and the story
began to get around as being at the pool
report and as I recall I indicated not
wisely but there was a Glee that since
senator Kennedy was a democratic money
that he would have said kiss my elephant
and
did it did deflect the incident a little
bit but but to me to me it made the
senator McGovern seem all the all the
better a candidate and I noticed you've
got a km a button on your lapel left
over from that moment I think on balance
we probably benefited from it
other questions
is it shameful to fragance denying
responsibility for the campaign mr.
Thompson in fear and loathing 72
ureteric was actually much harsher
against Hubert Humphrey that against
Nixon I was wondering is that because
Nixon was essentially unavailable or
your expectations for the Democrats were
so much greater I think it was because
uh I was offended more by Humphreys
treachery that I was by Nixon's pure
evil
guys I still miss yeah he was a giant
and it was Humphreys treachery that to
find him in Christ with the Nixon
treachery didn't work that it admitted
it was like a ingrained sort of the
price of doing business with excellent
was assumed he was treacherous and real
treacherous bad evil treacherous I
remember George in California we went on
it's a some big stage a theater
somewhere and you and Humphrey were
there together and he just [ __ ] he he
had hundreds um utterly treacherous
thing like I'm a Jew too and I'll fight
to the death for them you know numbers
against Jews I don't know have some
other double-cross that yeah I remember
you we were back into the caverns of
some kind of a film studio and you
crossed paths with uh with Humphrey and
California was a nasty one that that was
a bastard yeah and at that point I
remember your anger I forgotten exactly
what the issue was I don't know what
copter that plane full of billions of
dollars in that it landed somewhere in
the desert of you you told me about
companies money coming into the Frank is
so [ __ ] inscrutable I guess that's
what oh that yes well but there was that
I remember real anger there and then
that you filming commercials were
somewhat some show like a sunny news
show or something
and I can't believe we went by those
days when those satellites you know we
actually had to deal with film moving it
and then these moments were precious I
remember George and Hubert ever thought
Hubert was a bad person until I had to
deal with even you know in front he was
a treacherous bastard he had no more
honor no more ethics or no more decency
despite all of his bleeding or at
[ __ ] that he put up he wrote an
anti-communist goddamn wave and wherever
he was he was a liberal in the word
sorry well I'll get off
but I remember Georgia and Hubert
meeting there and that was that pure
anger George was offended that I was and
I think that I yeah but that time I got
pretty nasty I'm going to personalize
the campaign and ivory offended me I'm
very answering question
and Bend the George and I believe that's
the that was the Sherrod instinct I mean
I Senator McGovern how did you deal with
Hunter Thompson and rolling stone on the
campaign trail it was me
trial was the book jacket in which it
showed the hunter and I sitting on an
airplane and the inscription under the
picture is the senator George McGovern
is showing is showing here imploring dr.
Hunter Thompson to be his vice president
I I don't know whether that sold books
or not but I must say I run into that
book even yet all over this country it's
become a kind of a folk piece of the 72
campaign I hope hunter has gotten as
rich from it as it appears to me
traveling around the country running
into it everywhere I go
little boys loathe to either say one
other thing that book was written for
Rolling Stones as they as the campaign
progressed it wasn't something written
from the hindsight of the campaign those
chapters rolled off his typewriter as
the campaign moved along and it was
really rather remarkable the afore side
he had is what was going to happen he
forecast the results of the primary bed
and described a lot of things in a in a
rather I thought prophetic context so
you may be a little bit startled by some
of the language you've heard here today
but with Hunter
what-you-see-is-what-you-get this all I
can say is that Frank described that
book acted I'd forgotten exactly how he
worded it but I remember it was
something to the effect this is the most
inaccurate book about the campaign but
the most truthful and there's a lot a
lot of thought behind that statement I
think it pretty well described it and
it's the reason I enjoyed traveling with
him during the campaign
there are other questions from the
audience let me just say that I'll tour
you were the most fun I ever had on any
campaign it's a it was all like that I'd
still be running around here with a
notebook in my head wondering what the
[ __ ] people were talking about but that
didn't I don't care anymore
but uh I know better but you we cared
then about that I care what you said and
you said some wretched wretched
disastrous things uh I remember one of
the porns hospital and um st. Louis
driving out there and try to get me
Kelton's medical records thanks revering
about a thousand percent anyway oh he
did care that it was fun and I thank you
for that for bringing me into a
humdinger though that's the way of
participating in politics I'm into local
politics well but that's way it should
be
even at 22 percent loss I was going to
ask
there's also out of that there's a book
called boys on the bus which became out
Tim prowess became a famous book from 72
campaign and I just want to ask Morris
Dees what what it was like climate was
like when you were on the road with some
of these journalists and on the bus and
kind of capturing so when you write when
you write letters you can fax him in and
you can have a lot of free time on a
campaign after being on the back of the
bus
with a hundred for a while I had to go
to al-anon and that was just that was
just from the smoke because I didn't
don't do stuff like that I grew up in
the six pack generation it was fun to be
on the back of the bus I got to know a
lot of people Gary Hart was there
occasionally and Shirley MacLaine and
Warren Beatty and everybody and Frank
dropped in occasionally and set us all
straight it was it was a great
experience for me and it obviously took
a person who from Alabama and from a
small cotton farm never been outside the
state much until senator McGovern called
me for somebody and he thought I ran a
direct mail printing company because one
of his age Yancy Martin a black guy
who's from under me misunderstood what I
did that in government get this letter
out and he just asked me to come do the
printing that's when companies could
give money and Dwayne Andrews and others
knowing that pretty well but uh as it
turned out it was a great opportunity
for me to meet a lot of people do
again and to then go on to work and it's
called as finance chairman and Senator
Kennedy's and others so it was a great
education I saw it as a as a crusade
also because I was very very much
opposed to the war in Vietnam and as
much as I was any outrages that the Ku
Klux Klan and in brutal Southern
sheriffs and others had committed
against blacks in the south I thought it
was a civil rights moral outrage what
our country was doing to the citizens of
North and South Vietnam so it gave me a
chance to be a part of a worldwide
crusade for human rights just curious if
the panelists recall the the four that
were on the campaign if they recall
where they were when Watergate occurred
Frank do you have any when they win the
break-in it comes in the [ __ ] hotel
well I think I was probably the first to
know that the morning after the morning
after the break-in I was in New York
having breakfast with Larry O'Brien we
were going over things like where the
delegates were going to be seated in the
order of the roll call and important
matters and agenda and in the middle of
breakfast the head waiter brought over a
phone and said Mr Bryan you got a call
and Larry took the call and he's
listening and he was talking to Iraq a
pristine who was his deputy and a
wonderful man and who had been calling
him then from Washington and I'm
listening to Larry and he's saying
things like they did really how many of
them and and they all had Spanish names
that's odd
he says
ah but then he got to the crucial crush
he said well what did they take really
well he said keep me posted
IRA and he hangs up and he said to him
well now that's fasting he said that
somebody some people broke into our
office last night cops say they all had
Spanish names they didn't take anything
we had a lot of typewriters a lot of TV
sets they didn't take anything and as
well okay you know now let's get serious
about hotel rooms and how many we get
and where and then Larry said something
that that kind of stuck with me he said
you know it's odd he said the cop said
it looked as though they were prepared
to stay there all weekend and I thought
my first thought I must say was in
Washington without air-conditioning was
the Watergate hesitation but then I
began to began to think about well if
that really is odd and of course a
couple of days later it turned out that
James McCord who was head of security
for the Nixon campaign was one of the
burglars the only one without a Spanish
name and that sort of convinced us that
the Nixon campaign at least was in on it
and knowing Nixon's character over the
years it seemed to us highly unlikely
that he would not be involved himself
and that's how it turned out but I I
must say that first morning it didn't
didn't strike me as a as an event that
was going to shake the nation as paper I
kept telling you I could make one thing
clear that what a great high pleasures
of I have my life is meeting Frank
mankiewicz and making and being friends
with him through this campaign I've
never before his sentencing a situation
where I could drive out to let the Chevy
Chase at 2:00 in the morning hammer on
the door and wake up Frank and demand to
know what the real story was we got to
be a good friend for that he was the
best of that briefing
good person to work with but maybe the
best ever
I hate to think of a beer but I think he
was right on them believe if you came
over this or like that I'd that's the
board you it's true
I'm waiting okay did some questions from
the audience
yes in the bar back there good if anyone
has any additional stories or memorable
quotes from Spiro Agnew regarding George
McGovern a little I don't know about
that Doug but centra McGovern made a
decision early on he probably doesn't
even know he made he may not have made
it but Gary said he did this felt this
fella named McCord in the White House
also is a Security Director for the
committee to re-elect the president and
the National Republican community RNC
and being a southern trial lawyer when
we heard did four days after break-in
that this McCord fella was in a you know
I said well I call Gary cuz McGovern you
know had said and I think he was rather
naive but if he became president I would
be his attorney general that was only
twenty something years old but maybe
that's how he lured me into the campaign
but uh so I took him serious though and
so I said well to Gary I said let's file
a suit against the Republican Committee
and the community really liked the
president and all that because you know
it's just no coincidences McCord guys
there security director both of these
groups and also got caught in at
Watergate building so four or five days
after the break-in with central
government approval we file a civil
lawsuit they had Bennett Williams and
Joe Califano signed their name to it and
I drafted it and filed it in federal
district court here in Washington DC and
I had lunch recently with John
Ehrlichman because he was one of the
fellas we salute Ehrlichman Haldeman
stands Mitchell we should held everybody
and in committee reelected president
Hall I mean early men told me he said
you know what mr. Bennett Williams
quickly took their depositions of
everybody and it nailed them down to
stories that screw them later because
they can never change their story say
they had been no Watergate scandal
nothing had broken out mr. Williams had
the inside story from the Watergate and
the deep throat and everybody else so he
knew what to ask and he and he deposed
all those officials and all of them had
to take a story under oath about their
relationship with everything and late as
mr. Ehrlichman told me the other day
lunch he said he said you know that
lawsuit really locked us into a position
and that was a maybe had something to do
with this mr. Nixon demise Ehrlichman
incidentally Ehrlichman incidentally
this August has a documentary on
Watergate he's been working on and it
apparently has some new revelations
about that unless that's just a ploy to
get us to see it but he's he's been
working very hard on a documentary which
will be coming out on Watergate this
August yes
Doug as the lawsuit was filed really I
was thinking of money because creep had
a lot of money and I was hoping to get
it for the campaign but actually it was
settled for land $700,000 after the you
know Nixon step down there was nothing
to that was it though they were they
were dealing with like millions and
brown bags they had a lot 7s Mississippi
who kept traveling back and forth with
lunch bags full of nine million dollar
bills
oh there were bigger yes sir this one's
for Senator McGovern I understand he
flew with Bob Dole and gordon Liddy to
Richard Nixon's funeral what was that
like senator McGovern right I make a lot
of that other than to say that it seemed
to me that the thing to do is a former
President of the United States and I
thought it was the proper thing to be
there to recognize his office he was a
dominant figure in American politics
during most of my public career so I
didn't share in some of the more
excessive praise of the president after
his death but I did think the least I
could do is be a present for his funeral
David II in here see 100 Thompson's
obituary of Richard Nixon when George
rolled over let's plays that he rolled
over and he wrote and I had a gorgeous
town I wouldn't read that a bit worried
but had been for George kvn at the
funeral I was so outraged I watched that
thing
Jesus what dole Wilson Kissinger and
then you George of all people I thought
this can't go on I was I would sitting
out on the beach somewhere smoking
marijuana was chief Ambrose his
biography and I was so sentimental with
that even convinced me that Nixon really
was a good guy a development writers
blocked like well yeah he really was you
give us a lot of fun but then when I saw
you that's all Kissinger and I saw dole
it just was all pure rotten politics
today they came in front of me like a
red orange blaze in my eyes and then
that's when I wrote that thing about
Nixon yes sir
yes the role of the press that a
presidential campaign is always
interesting
one thing I've enjoyed about the 72
campaign reading about it is the stark
comparisons of how journalists described
Nixon versus McGovern for example
Thompson described Nixon as a werewolf
and went on within a long bit about
McGovern's incredible smile Norman
Mailer in st. George and the Godfather
had a nice passage with McGovern liking
him to an astronaut and he referred to
Nixon as a somber Undertaker's assistant
and even more moderate journalists of
showed a clear bias in favor of McGovern
in light of the fact that for his whole
political career Nixon talked about the
bias of the press I wonder if the
panel's would address Nixon's view yeah
he was a lying dog I and had every
reason to fear the president I remain I
remain amazed that serious observers of
American politics have anything good
left to say about Richard Nixon or even
that they had it then you know there's a
yum there's a portion of the Nixon tapes
that's referred to in the Haldeman
Diaries and which sy Hirsch wrote about
a couple years ago and the AP chronicled
as well that to me it's just it's the
beginning in the end of Richard Nixon
and I followed him a long time I was in
California when he emerged as a
congressional candidate in 1972 on the
15th of May George Wallace was shot out
here in Laurel I think and the FBI very
early on had a report turned out to be
accurate that the would-be assassin was
a man named Arthur Bremer
and he lived in Milwaukee and within an
hour to Nixon has a conversation with
Charles Colson in the White House
ah in which he tells him that what he
ought to do is get somebody to go out to
Milwaukee to Bremer's apartment break-in
before the FBI gets there and seals it
off and plant McGovern literature the
out faith that's the President of the
United States talking and I think once
you see that read that story you you
lose whatever shred of respect might
remain yeah I know he went to China but
you know who we miss while we were in
California together at the time of the
thing Frank and I had two distinctions
we were both going to UCLA with two
other distinguished California's named
Haldeman and Ehrlichman and many years
Frank has always amused me with remark
that at least he and I were still voting
this is when Haldeman was still alive
but the Gerry Voorhies campaign I didn't
know who Jerry Voorhees was it was one
of the first votes of my life and I
voted for a Democratic congressman who
was called a communist because he had
visited Russia with a congressional
committee during the war and the
campaign which followed against Helen
Douglas unleashed a degree of
malevolence that I have that always
followed Nixon for me
and I remembered rejoicing each time he
was defeated
I remember saying after the California
gubernatorial thing hurray
no more Nixon it's why I'm nervous even
here talking about it because this is
his town I'm just a country boy if that
sumbitch comes back he ain't gonna be
looking kindly on me well he's but also
into it it's also important to remember
that the press could have probably been
harder on Nixon than they actually were
he did not have you know he didn't hold
any press conferences did not make
himself available to the press and
basically I buttermilk is and throwing
up softballs that every one of those
televised things do you believe in the
Good Fairy and motherhood
what having to voice what about 22
points though it says we didn't lose I
think the I think a major contributor to
the to the situation also was the was
the media's total unwillingness to pick
up the Watergate story at all except for
the Washington Post
it was both suspect part partly because
there is this inbred reluctance on the
part of any media outlet to begin a
story by saying the Washington Post said
today and the alternative of that of
course was to get some investigative
reporters of your own go out and do some
work and not a great reluctance to do
that to bringing the result is of the
closest most carried that story all by
itself where the Punishers the st. Louis
New York Times do they have a turn away
and yes it was it's mattress one that
did that they did for themselves in that
statement that I quoted that you know
they've really had happened well the few
papers of the yeah but television left
it alone except for one piece by Walter
Cronkite
Morse you wouldn't get in this not on
that exact point but one of the legacies
I thought that the 1972 campaign would
leave would be campaign finance reform
and we did come in with the limit on
contributions and I think it's sad today
to see how both parties have abused that
and I thought I would hope some kind of
way would that could be straightened out
because McGovern's campaign provement
prove that small contributors around the
country would support a campaign the
Republicans know this works they have a
very large mailing list yet we still see
that we have to go to Indonesia and
other countries to raise money for our
campaigns and I think that just Sully's
the whole process
two questions here John Prados first and
then we'll get you okay mr. mankiewicz
mentions the the story about Bremer and
Coulson and that illustrates I think a
certain attitude towards dirty tricks
other than Watergate at the lower level
at the campaign level in the Republican
campaign in 72 I know those kinds of
things were prevalent in New York City
where I saw I would like to get some
kind of reading on on how detrimental to
McGovern's efforts do you think were
sort of counter political activities by
Republican campaign organizations dirty
drinks I'm not sure understand the
question how much dirty tricks affected
the campaign Oh other than Watergate
Jonathan a little dirty trick I think I
think to some extent not uh not an
extraordinary amount I think the they
affect the campaign if they're ignored
if they have been adequately adequately
reported all of them cluding them let's
say the Bremer thing result could very
well have been different I was impressed
with what Bob Shrum had to say to which
is that that the the tragedy of 1972 was
not the george mcgovern loss but the the
nature of the loss if he if three or
four things had gone differently
including I think the problem with the
senator Eagleton he probably would have
lost but he would have won ten fifteen
states on a reasonable number of
electoral votes at worst maybe one
breakfast and then have been and then
have been a fairly obvious choice for
the Democratic Party in 1976 and served
two distinguished terms as president if
it varies in the press coverage was a
huge factor
I think so it was sure it would wait oh
I hope your president won't be executive
so because because a lot of the true
events of the campaign went on covered
including Watergate for openers
if the coverage had been better you
think it would have altered the
yong-chol yeah it would have altered the
outcome whether it would have changed
the weather it would have meant the
difference in winning and losing I don't
know but it certainly would have meant
the difference between a landslide and a
respectable loss well Nixon's a player
in this as well I mean his foreign
policy and domestic maneuverings late in
the term also you know showed him to be
a better leader than perhaps people had
thought since 1970 even though I don't
really know exactly I mean I don't agree
with that at all but any incumbent
president has many many coins in the
fountain to use to take advantage of the
position and that's considered sort of
fair game but what I objected to about
the whole Nixon thing was coming to
Washington first of all I'm not wild
about Washington as a place to be every
politician that ever lost election still
lives here and it makes me a little
nervous
somehow I feel I'm supporting them but
the thing about not just Watergate and
not just dirty tricks but the campaign
itself was a foul campaign almost all of
the public statements were lies most of
the commercials which were run by the
Nixon campaign were untruths and they
did it with a straight face and and the
American press supposedly so vigilant
let them get away with it today they run
little things about commercials and say
well this isn't really true and that
there was none of that in 72 and here we
are with wonderful fellow named
Guggenheim making honest commercials
from a government that are truly
representing him and his position and so
we were here we were operating in an
absolutely marked deck and not getting
any cards I mean it's hard to win under
those circumstances I don't care what
the game is and I fought the press I
fought every element of the press for
not at some point in time saying wait a
minute if it hasn't proved that he's in
soon you think I don't laugh I don't
think they've improved now all they were
everybody polls everybody else is worse
than
I mean I think today every news
organization in Charlotte we run polls
on sheriff's races to the degree that
they used to do for presidential
elections a campaign to you know we of
course I don't have real senators like
other states because we have Jesse Helms
but he spent he spent so much money he's
been 31 million dollars defeating Jim
hunt one time and I at my house got 22
mailings some of them in color anybody
who has a dumb enough mailing
organization to send me 22 million for
Jesse Helms either has an excess of
money or a lack of brains but the whole
president the lower levels today and I'm
in that business and have been for most
of my adult life the press today is an
absolutely derelict I mean with every
pen I pick up the paper they say the
whole business about the campaign reform
thing and this and that and that's what
everybody in America is thinking about
nobody in Charlotte I can't talk to
Washington DC but ain't a soul in
Charlotte that the least interested in
campaign reform because they view that
is some rich guy giving money to some
other rich guy and not coming to them
for they don't care Stan yet that's all
the press seems to be involved in he
owns I believe the Charlotte leaders is
a corrector your feet that's right I'm
just a little weekly newspaper but I
didn't get to write in it and I say what
I think yeah but Michelle wonder then
what do you make of the numbers and the
more untrustworthy Clinton is received
to be in the by the electorate the more
electable but I'm not so sure the
electorate feels that no it's the media
thinks the media thinks well I
understand the polls or our polls of
polls they ought to be in Warsaw the
point I make is that everybody wants to
know is the president working for me and
nobody much gives a damn about what
happened in Arkansas 15 years ago in
those terms
I live in a town with two percent
unemployment I live in a town of
discovered racial justice because all of
a sudden there's no employees defined
and people change colors overnight in
some racist establishments so I live in
a very successful town as is
are many places where they don't give a
damn about these other things let me get
this gentleman and he's been patiently
waiting enter the fray I think we have a
clue as to what the panel thinks of
Richard Nixon could could could you get
into what the campaign's relationship
was with former President Johnson was
Larry brave well it was not not not uh
terribly important Johnson and taken
himself out of the presidential race and
in effect taken himself out of a lot of
politics he was not well obviously he
certainly didn't admire Senator McGovern
position on the war I think paid him a
visit during the campaign went down
talked to him as I recall the president
advised him to take a nap every day
which is good advice but but know that
that relationship I don't think was very
good at the beginning of the campaign
but I don't think it had very much
impact on the election the president in
effect let it be known had obviously had
let it be known that the senator
McGovern was not his choice as the
nominee but he didn't do very much about
it he respected the judgment of the
party and the primaries and the
convention and he stayed out of it thank
you I think we're going to have to stop
I'm sorry I can't get the other
questions but I'm trying to keep us on
time I'd like to thank all of our
panelists more or less okay one last
question if again I just seen origin
I've been good over this and it's hard
to be right
why did I Harold Hughes betray you
that day in February I've been going
back over that book and I'm in the
details when Harold Hughes went off for
muskie it's an unanswered question it's
haunted me ever since then he was the on
him he had died by then
oh man it was empty too I don't recall
made real I wish I get tally admit Jesus
and his whole mystery will we're gonna
take we'll take a break just for about
five minutes like to thank our panelists
very much
how the heat got good will heat the cold
about is